je suis lucide en bertone j'ai eu l'idée
de ré incroyable couvert comestibles
notre mission débarrasser la planète des
couverts en plastique jetables et sauver
le monde
une bouchée à la fois je dois avouer que
je suis vraiment déçu d'accord je vais
leur quart écoute la beyoncé qui est en
toi mon ami au quai coûtait moins bien
les incroyables mangeable comestibles
incroyable comestibles chacun son point
de vue mais c'est vous qui payez ces
prêts à relever le grand défi de l'esp
et d'équipements si on réussit à relever
le défi du parcours haut niveau avec les
galeries souterraines les plus profondes
du nouveau mexique
on sera prêts à relever les défis de
l'environnement économique d'aujourd'hui
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que ça va j'ai fait une formation
rcp ouais il est mort pour renforcer
notre esprit d'équipé
c'est une opportunité c'est comme si
nous avions notre propre et ce quel pied
qu'est-ce qui peut être pire que cette
situation imagine cette situation mais
en plus tu es tu es mort ça fait dix
jours qu'on est bloqués ans caveau la
plus longue durée qu'un être humain et
tony sans avoir ni manger dans environ
une semaine et dans cette grotte ils
nous manque les deux alors une source
alimentaire qu'on n'a pas encore étudié
je crois que c'est une décision que nous
devrions prendre ensemble et il faut
penser collectif et non individuel
mon estomac était plutôt individuelle
dans sa façon de penser amine el aima
winstein je suis là winch team de
personnes règle numéro 1 suivez les
instructions à la seconde où je les
donne je suis déçu par chacun d'entre
vous si jamais il venait à manger
brandon je me demande comment aussi
prendra qui est suivi un cours de
préparation de sa chimie nous attend
pays avait le découpage de la
championnat on a travaillé sur le saut
[Musique]
vous avez les yeux et les mains d'un
homme violence je le sais parce que je
connais des hommes jeunes qu'est ce
qu'un homme violent peut vraiment croire
qu'il trouvera la paix
[Musique]
si vous avez besoin de quelque chose
vous êtes là toute la nuit je vais vous
dire fait le double zéro
oui je suis là toute la nuit je croyais
que vous étiez le réceptionniste
réceptionniste barman guardian nuit
propriétaire
[Musique]
à cet endroit depuis combien de temps
environ un an c'est un ami qui m'a cédé
on entendu dire que tu avais pas d'amis
j'en ai plus je suis en train de
m'extraire
une situation très compliquée parce que
tu me sors de l'argent de quelqu'un
d'autre je ne vois pas de cette manière
mais quelqu'un voit ainsi tu sais qui je
suis donner un genre et toi t'en as a
way le genre à vouloir rester en vie
sentimentale et je parle sans savoir ce
qui se passe parce que je sais vraiment
pas ce qui se passe ici n'est pas dans
la confiance il faudrait que je te casse
confiance alors que tu me fais pas
confiance tu veux mourir
il ya quelque chose qui me gêne chez toi
c'est toi qui est à l'origine de tout ça
tu veux que je te dise que je suis
désolé
je suis pas celui du crois tu ne veux
pas l'être vêtus les
[Musique]
je suppose que tu avais un flingue dans
son cercle moi et j'en ai un mais je
suis tombé sur un couteau
[Musique]
non
nous sommes dans les pme
[Musique]
nous
saint front we did you tube meilleur
papa darwin qui n'est pas venu et c'est
moins grave
[Musique]
l'opération habilayn est connu pour
avoir été l'une des plus sanglantes
batailles de cette sombre guerre
la compagnie tout entier rohr a été
massacré les mines au canada
j'ai prié pour un miracle
ce fut cet homme qui s'appelait pics
mills à sauver bien des vies ils étaient
censés recevoir la médaille d'honneur
mais il n'a pas eu sa médaille que la
justice est lente de justice injuste
la médaille d'honneur est la plus haute
distinction militaire décerné pour les
actes d'héroïsme présenter un dossier
complet pour une réhabilitation de
statut monsieur victime mariage code
hoffman ministère de la défense tu nous
ici pour entendre votre version
l'histoire si vous voulez connaître
l'histoire de pi l'aisne il va vous
falloir parler avec les hommes de
terrain mais j'ai jamais vu une horreur
comme habile n hills est descendu
l'hélico il a sauvé défi évacuer des
hommes qui connaissaient même pas ça
ressemble à une opération suicide dans
le suicide est une forme de lâcheté
liedson darger c'était un monument de
courage je lui disais sans arrêt de
remonter
goûter pas il était là pour sauver des
vies et c'est ce qu'ils faisaient
pourquoi vous êtes là parce que vous
êtes là n'avait rien à faire là comme
nous tous d'ailleurs
cette cei c'était une [ __ ] danton
loupe on s'est fait massacrer par notre
propre camp
dans ce fameux rapport il ya des choses
qui manquent qui est à l'origine qui a
conçu l'opération abidal évite de flore
est tombé là-dedans pourquoi
l'accréditation avait bizarrement
disparu du document original est ce que
tu te rends compte de ce que tu risques
je ne t'ai jamais vu reculer devant le
moindre obstacle en général nous sommes
jugés sur nos actions mais je suis
convaincu que ce sont nos indécision
notre manque de courage d'une scène je
vais révéler toute l'histoire
ça semble un tantinet dangereux mais ce
sera un grand moment télévision obtenir
cette médaille morbide pour les hommes
que j'ai perdu c'est probablement la
seule chose descente que je pourrais
garder une seule hier le père de pixels
bagarre il est en fin de vie de mourir
les peuples dur que de perdre à nos fais
ce que tu veux fiston parce que la
valeur de gars comme betrand darger met
le doigt sur tout ce qu'ils n'ont pas le
respect de la vie d'autrui
je dois finaliser ce rapport
bennis et ce jeune homme qui nous a
promis de redonner honneur et dignité à
ceux qui sont tombés au combat et dans
le sacrifice n'aura pas été vain ils ne
soient jamais oubliées
les files album en solo sans animaux
théo
[Musique]
en délicatesse
basta
on dit
[Musique]
ils sont sans pitié
c'est par par ailleurs
ils tuent et massacrent aveuglément
ils souillent le sol d'angleterre une
terre qui nous ne défendrons jamais
maintenant le temps est venu de leur
parler la seule langue qu'ils puissent
comprendre
[Musique]
non
ça vous souhaitez
bouclier
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
g
si m
m
oda est avec nous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ouais ça